the marshmallow would begin to travel at
99.9% the speed of light reaching the
earth's surface in less than a
millisecond as the marshmallow enters
our atmosphere it would begin to slam
into the atmospheric
particles at this ridiculous speed these
particles would actually punch into the
marshmallow and stay there so the
marshmallow would actually gain weight
as it hurdled toward Earth this highly
energetic scenario would most likely
cause the marshmallow to rip
apart this would be a Saving Grace for
us down below because it would create
explosions that would dissipate the
energy during its trajectory